within its first month on air the loud
house became the number one children's
animated series on American television
we can't believe that we have already
watched two seasons and we can't wait to
see what is coming next in season three
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know more about the terrible
things that could happen to our favorite
characters if you love the loud house as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you what the
loud house will look like in 2018 in
2017 many people have the courage to
talk about the sexual harassment in the
industry and those who are responsible
for this it all started with a film
mogul Harvey Weinstein when many women
accused him of taking advantage of the
situation to manipulate people into
giving him what he wants it encouraged
women to share their experience with the
hashtag me too created by Toronto Byrne
and promoted by actress Alyssa Milano
this was when millions of people all
around the world started talking about
what they went through and some of these
stories included celebrities many
artists saw their reputation being
ruined when people finally told the
truth about what happens one of them was
Chris Savino the creator of the loud
house as many as 12 women accused Savino
of sexual harassment
it included unwanted sexual advances and
threats of blacklisting after their
relationships have ended and it is not
something new as some of the reports
date back at least a decade when he was
working on shows like Rocko's Modern
Life and the Powerpuff Girls Savino was
suspended before Nickelodeon finally
decided to fire him from his own show a
spokesperson said that they take
allegations of misconduct very seriously
and they are committed to fostering a
safe and professional workplace
environment that is free of harassment
or other kinds of inappropriate conduct
Nickelodeon Group president also said
that he encourages anyone who has been
the subject or has witnessed an
uncomfortable situation at work to speak
up and there is probably one thing that
you are all wondering about what is
going to happen to the loud house now
that Chris Savino has
fired does that mean that we won't have
the chance to watch our favorite show
anymore don't worry the show will
continue to air on Nickelodeon and be in
production season three is already
scheduled to premiere in 2018 so we're
pretty sure that we're going to see our
favorite characters once again
we are going to see 26 more episodes for
a total of 78 but what is going to
happen to them during a loud house panel
in 2017 the team talked about the
characters that they created for only
one episode and how much they fell in
love with them in such a short time this
is why they want to see them once again
and they will probably be back in season
three one of them is Lunas crush
Sam from Elvis for love in this episode
the kids found a love letter addressed
to out loud this is why they all went
crazy and started wondering who the
letter was for they found out that their
parents were actually the ones
exchanging love letters but that didn't
stop Luna from sending the love letter
to her crushed and this is when we
learned that Sam was actually a girl but
she certainly got our attention we don't
even know if Sam loves Luna too but we
can't wait to hear more about this maybe
this is what we will see in the third
season when Sam will come back we also
heard that some other friends are going
to come back one of them is haiku Lucy's
friends who appears in the episode dance
dance resolution just like Lucy she
speaks with a calm and motionless tone
and is fascinated by poetry and Gothic
literature the only other thing we know
about her is that she has a crush on a
vampire looking boy who just turned 200
will she ever meet him in season 3 we
can't wait to see what this boy looks
like three other characters that we will
have the chance to see once again are
rusty Liam and Zach from hand-me-down er
the team said that we should see many
other friends in the next season but we
still don't know who we also think that
the Casagrande family will return you
probably remember them from the loudest
mission relative chaos when Ronnie Ann
and the Santiago family decided to live
in their house the voice actors of Miss
Santiago and Frieda Karl
Carlos er Laurie and Lincoln posted on
Twitter that they were recording an
episode together the two actors who
played Bobby in Carlotta also posted
about this on Instagram we would be
really happy to see them once again even
if
it's just for one episode when the
animated series started there were so
many characters that each of them
portrayed a simple stereotype Luna is
the rock star Lola is the princess and
Lucy is the God but as the animator got
a chance to know them these characters
became more complicated and this is what
really made them come to life they were
not just one among many sisters they
each had a different personality and
some characteristics that we loved and
made them unique this is why one of the
girls is probably one of your favorite
characters this is also why the story
doesn't have to be focused on Lincoln
only anymore
now we can give each girl the attention
that she deserves this is why the
animators started telling stories from
the point of view of another sister and
now they have 10 times more stories to
tell we think that in the third season
animators will have the chance to focus
even more on other sisters and Lincoln
will sometimes be less important which
sister would you like to hear more about
don't be shy to tell us in the comment
section down below the love of the
family is one of the most important
things in the show and the team thinks
that this is what people really connect
to the writers are willing to dedicate
an entire page of the script which is a
lot of time on screen just to make you
believe that the characters really
apologize to each other with no jokes
they want to take the time to make
people believe that this is a real
family there will always be a joke right
after but you'll just laugh even more
after feeling so emotional this is why
we think that in season 3 we will see
more episodes featuring emotional topics
we just hope that it won't get too dark
even though Lucy would like it but we
are ready to feel closer to the loud
family and you what is one thing that
you would really like to see in the next
season of the loud house don't be shy to
answer in the comment section down below
and that's it for what the loud house
will look like in 2018 for more stories
like this make sure you watch 5 TV shows
that copies the loud house thanks for
watching and see you next time